climate change is already impacting
every continent and ocean on the planet
hundreds of scientists and experts came
to this conclusion in a new report for
the United Nations the report has taken
five years to make and is part of the
definitive study on climate change to
date here's some of the reports biggest
findings when it comes to climate
changes impacts summarized on this map
in the report scientists use a scale to
explain how confident they are about a
given impact and whether it's caused by
climate change even when other factors
like pollution play a role for now let's
focus on impacts that scientists are
very confident can be linked to climate
change and undisputed facts will be
indicated like this so let's start with
the oceans which have been getting
warmer since 1970 scientists are highly
confident warming has been caused by
greenhouse gases that humans have been
pumping into the atmosphere the warming
has massive consequences one example in
the Northeast Atlantic fish zooplankton
seabirds and other species are moving
towards the poles to escape the heat and
in the Mediterranean some species have
died on mass while new warm water
species have invaded how does this
affect people well ninety percent of the
people who work in fisheries come from
the world's poorer countries and won't
have jobs if fish move or disappear no
fish also means no food especially for
places like central and western Africa
peru colombia and elsewhere which rely
on the sea for food security and it's
not just sea life that's affected
animals and plants in Europe North
America Chile and Malaysia have recently
moved an average of 17 kilometers
towards the poles and 11 meters up an
altitude to escape the heat but moving
isn't an option for coral reefs coral
reefs around the world are bleaching and
dying in increasing numbers coral reefs
are home to more than four thousand
species of fish the irreversible loss of
reefs would impact 500 million people
who rely on reef ecosystems for five
billion u.s.
a year finally there's the Arctic so
many changes are happening in the Arctic
that scientists say a regime shift is
taking place there the Arctic permafrost
is thawing and shrubs are literally
creeping upwards into areas where they
couldn't grow before animals that rely
on ice like polar bears and seals are
being severely affected especially in
the warming summers in turn food
security for the indigenous people who
live in the Arctic is threatened and
that's just the tip of the iceberg as
glaciers continue to melt worldwide
because of climate change
raising sea levels pretty scary stuff
huh
so is climate change already impacting
you where you live let us know by
commenting on this video and don't
forget to subscribe to aj+